weihnachten in bethlehem tausende
christen aus aller welt feiern im
heiligen land die geburt jesu christi
für mehr miteinander deutschlands
kirchen rufen in ihren
weihnachtsbotschaften zum zusammenhalt
auf in einer polarisierten gesellschaft
und ermittlungspanne in recklinghausen
im fall eines zwei jahre lang vermissten
jungen ist die polizei einem
entscheidenden hinweis
offenbar nicht nachgegangen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers heiligabend 2009 10
meine damen und herren herzlichen dank
dass wir sie auch heute über das
geschehen auf dieser welt informieren
dürfen
die christen auf der ganzen welt feiern
heute die geburt jesu christi und wir
schauen zu beginn dieser sendung an den
ort an dem nach der überlieferung alles
begann nach bethlehem ein paar kilometer
südlich von jerusalem gelegenen im
palästinensischen westjordanland nach
christlicher überlieferung steht dort
die kirche die den geburtsort jesu
markiert für bethlehem ist das heute der
wichtigste tag des jahres ein tag der
feiern auch wenn niemand vor ort den
ungelösten konflikt zwischen israel und
den palästinensern ausblenden kann
annafest ist in bethlehem
wer zum weihnachtsfest in bethlehem will
kommt hier entlang meter hohe betonmauer
die sperranlage zwischen israel und den
palästinensischen gebieten ist natürlich
schon sehr bedrückend vor acht metern
betont zu stehen und zu sehen dass da
die weihnachtsprozession daran vorbei
führen muss doch einmal im jahr werden
die tore geöffnet für ihn erzbischof
pierbattista pizzaballa sieht von
jerusalem nach bethlehem ein zum
heiligen fest
der umzug gilt als einer der höhepunkte
zum schauspiel gehören auch
palästinensische pfadfinder mit
dudelsäcken unter den zuschauern
christen und moslems aus aller welt ein
buntes volksfest wenn auch mit weniger
besuchern hat in den letzten jahren sehr
schön hier es ist ein heiliger ort da wo
jesus geboren
man kann die schönheit richtig für
müller hallo ich bin total begeistert
von der stimmung hier die menschen
kommen aus aller welt her nur um diesem
tag zu genießen
der umzug führt zur geburtskirche dort
so heißt es war das jesus kind geboren
es ist eine der bedeutendsten stätten
für christen in aller welt
für fahrer mitri raheb aber hat dieser
tag auch einen bitteren beigeschmack
werde hierfür sollte geboren würde er
wahrscheinlich dass ich bin nach
bethlehem zu kommen sondern wie viele
andere mit der am checkpoint er geboren
genau dieses szenario zeigt das neueste
werk von street-art-künstler banksy die
krippe hat er persönlich hier vor
wenigen tagen abgeliefert als
weihnachtsgeschenk eine mahnung für den
frieden und wir gehen auch live nach
bethlehem anna was sind denn ihre
eindrücke heute von weihnachten am
geburtsort christi es ist sehr schön
hier hunderte feierten heute hier auf
dem platz hinter mir mit lauter musik
mit dudelsäcken und paukenschlag das
weihnachtsfest in letzter minute haben
sogar einige christen aus grabner die
genehmigung bekommen
an den feierlichkeiten teilzunehmen
richtig besinnlich wurde es dann in der
geburtskirche
dort hat man gemerkt dass man
tatsächlich an einem ganz besonderen ort
ist jetzt ist es ja so dass in den
nahost konflikt überhaupt gar keine
bewegung kommt wie viel frieden kann
denn von bethlehem ausgehen in dieser
heiligen nacht
leider beschränkt sich der frieden und
die besinnlichkeit hier auf die altstadt
oder auf die innenstadt um die stadt
herum sind hohe mauern und die
israelischen siedlungen werden immer
weiter ausgebaut
eigentlich gelten diese siedlungen als
illegal
doch die us amerikanische regierung hat
sich vor wenigen wochen hinter die
politik israels gestellt und damit steht
der siedlungsbau im westjordanland nicht
mehr per se im widerspruch zum
internationalen völkerrechts sagen die
amerikaner das ist natürlich das
gegenteil von einer entspannung im
nahost konflikt und wird von vielen
palästinensern mit großer sorge
betrachtet
herzlichen dank nach bethlehem wir
brauchen die demokratie aber derzeit
braucht die demokratie vor allem uns
eine mahnung aber auch eine warnung und
ein kernsatz in der diesjährigen
weihnachtsansprache des
bundespräsidenten
frank walter steinmeier sagte es brauche
bürgerinnen und bürger mit zuversicht
und tatkraft mit vernunft anstand und
solidarität
er lobt die die dagegen hielten wenn
schwächere angepöbelt werden oder
rassistische sprüche fallen die ganze
weihnachtsansprache gibt es morgen zu
sehen gleich nach den 19 uhr heute
nachrichten
an die hoffnung die die
weihnachtsbotschaft verbreitet erinnern
heute die beiden großen kirchen in
deutschland deren vertreter sprechen
aber auch über die probleme und
herausforderungen bei uns in deutschland
und in der welt 2009 10 sei ein
unruhiges jahr gewesen sagt der
katholische kardinal reinhard marx auch
deshalb heißt das motto der kirchen
heute gemeinsamkeit alexander pohl
für die insassen des jugendgefängnisses
in neuburg an der donau ist dies kein
einfaches weihnachtsfest gedanken an die
familie und die brüche im eigenen leben
bestimmen den tag
beistand erhalten sie von landesbischof
heinrich bedford strohm der
ratsvorsitzende der evangelischen kirche
in deutschland erinnert an das wort
christi dass alle menschen verbinde ich
war im gefängnis besucht das
christuskind als bruder aller menschen
so will auch kardinal reinhard marx die
botschaft jesu verstanden wissen
der vorsitzende der deutschen
bischofskonferenz mahnt die gläubigen an
weihnachten nicht nur die eigenen
interessen im blick zu haben sondern
sich für das wohl aller einzusetzen man
spürt einfach die ungleichheiten werden
größe auch weltweit die spannungen auch
ein nationalismus eine bezogenheit der
länder auf sich selber fundamentalismen
nehmen zu in den religionen auch in der
politik und das macht mir schon sorge
gemeinsamkeit zusammenhalt viele
menschen die heute den gottesdienst
besuchen wünschen sich dass die kirche
mehr als bisher ihren teil dazu beiträgt
dass sie offener wird und dass frauen
mehr rechte in der kirche ja und das ist
mein wunsch zur weihnacht die kirche
muss einfach schauen dass im modernen
bleibt was sonst hat sie verloren so wie
sie war so sie bleiben aber den
fortschritt nicht verpassen
erwartungen an die kirche die zumindest
an weihnachten wieder mehr in den
mittelpunkt der menschen rückt und auch
das heute an heiligabend mit einem
dramatischen appell hat sich der
uno-generalsekretär antonio guterres zum
krieg in syrien gemeldet nur eine
sofortige waffenruhe könne eine
humanitäre katastrophe und einen
massenexodus in die türkei verhindern
die armee von machthaber baschar
al-assad bombardiert die region idleb
mit russischer unterstützung
nach angaben von menschenrechtlern
starben dort heute bei einem angriff auf
eine schule zehn menschen darunter sechs
kinder
im atom streit zwischen den usa und
nordkorea stagnieren die verhandlungen
nordkorea droht mit neuen waffen tests
die nachbarländer china japan südkorea
haben auf einem gipfeltreffen jetzt klar
gemacht dass sie wollen dass die
abrüstungsgespräche weitergehen
chinas regierungschef li betonte der
konflikt müsse im dialog entschärft
werden
auch japans premier habe sagte die
gespräche mit nordkorea müssten in
schwung gehalten werden auch vorschläge
die sanktionen gegen nordkorea zu
lockern ging er nicht ein
nach deutschland ende juli hatten die
kollegen von aktenzeichen xy hier im zdf
von einem jungen aus dem ruhrgebiet
berichtet der seit zwei jahren vermisst
war am vergangenen freitag wurde der
heute 15-jährige zufällig entdeckt in
der wohnung eines 44 jährigen mannes in
recklinghausen der sitzt inzwischen in
untersuchungshaft
indes bereits direkt nach der sendung
hatte es hinweise auf diese wohnung
gegeben
warum der junge erst jetzt gefunden
wurde das muss erst geklärt werden
anselm stern mit mehr als 900 tage
vermisst marvin heute 15 jahre alt vor
vier tagen entdeckt in die polizei in
recklinghausen seit heute ist klar
die behörden hätten ihn schon viel
früher finden können schon im sommer gab
es den hinweis marvin könnte hier sein
das hat bei uns zunächst einmal große
betroffenheit ausgelöst
wir werden uns
diesen hinweis noch mal genauer
anschauen sehen was ist inhalt dieses
hinweises gewesen müssen dann schauen wo
gibt es individuelle oder
organisatorische versäumnisse im juli
2009 10 ist der fall marin thema bei
aktenzeichen xy nach der sendung kommt
der hinweis auf die wohnung eines
44-jährigen in recklinghausen
der mann ist vorbestraft weil er
kinderpornos besaß doch es passiert
nichts
erst jetzt monate später nach einem
neuen hinweis kommen die ermittler sie
suchen wieder nach
kinderpornographischem material zufällig
finden sie mal wenn in einem schrank in
der völlig vermüllten wohnung marvin das
ist auch die geschichte einer extrem
schwierigen kindheit seit dem tod seines
vaters hat er psychische probleme lange
zeit lebte in heimen
er sollte raus aus der schule und in
eine psychiatrische klinik im juni 2017
verlässt er eine wohngruppe in oer
erkenschwick und verschwindet man ihn
war klar dass tendenziell in der
nächsten zeit die aufnahme in der kinder
jung psychiatrie stattfinden wird und
all die dinge sind natürlich sachen die
13-jährigen jungen mann natürlich auch
belasten
marien wird jetzt von ärzten betreut ob
und wenn ja wann er zurück kann zu
seiner mutter ist unklar
weihnachten in frankreich und
gleichzeitig schon der zwanzigste tag an
dem die gewerkschaften gegen die
geplante rentenreform von präsident
manual makro protestieren und damit
viele menschen die zu freunden und
familien wollen natürlich besonders hart
treffen
auch heute gingen der streik im
öffentlichen verkehr weiter
nur 40 prozent der französischen
hochgeschwindigkeitszüge waren unterwegs
das wird sich auch auf den verkehr von
und nach deutschland massiv gestört auch
wieder viele pariser metro linien und
bei uns alle jahre wieder dieses problem
da ist der baum geschmückt
erwartungsvolle spannungsvoller
erwartung aber es fehlt noch das
geschenk und so hetzen heute
interessanterweise vor allem die männer
durch die einkaufsstraßen auf last
minute shopping tour am heiligen abend
ein phänomen mit vielen facetten wie
oliver deuker jetzt zeigt
alle jahre wieder irgendwie so ganz
plötzlich steht mal wieder weihnachten
vor der tür hannover innenstadt wer
jetzt noch unterwegs ist hat meist wenig
zeit auf der suche nach einem
weihnachtsgeschenk für wen und warum
erst auf den letzten drücker unterwegs
gestern war es dann doch zu spät noch in
der firma deswegen müssen wir heute noch
mal los wenn meine frau weil sich das zu
spät ergeben hat die hat immer so viel
gearbeitet und dass wir keine zeit
hatten über ihre wünsche zu sprechen und
jetzt habe ich das mitgekriegt und bin
gleich los heute morgen heute ist eben
der tag schön leer und deshalb geht's
jetzt los noch ein bisschen für meine
frau was zu kaufen
auffällig viele herren in den
kaufhäusern heute das last minute
weihnachtsgeschenk der männersache die
damen haben wir festgestellt ein
bisschen anders strukturiert man geht
doch eher losmann man steckt schon mal
die preise man guckt was ist so vorrätig
auch heute es einige takte herren sieht
ist ein bisschen näher als aggressiv
falsch aber so ist angespannt
hereinkommen
und dann habe ich total glücklich und
entspannt das irgendwie hin gekriegt zu
haben womit kann man die liebsten
erfreuen vielleicht sogar so richtig
punkten also was ist das optimale
weihnachtsgeschenk eine gemeinsame
unternehmungen zusammen zeit verbringen
schöne stunden gemeinsam haben und bei
ihnen natürlich was praktisch ist ein
eishockeyschläger für meinen sohn zb
werbung markt hannover vom geschenk der
einkaufsstress ist hier nichts zu merken
feiern am morgen des heiligen abends
alles richtig gemacht
und wer es auch auf den letzten drücker
nicht geschafft hat der muss jetzt auf
den weihnachtsmann hoffen
der gibt sich immerhin richtig viel mühe
überall auf der welt pünktlich zu sein
gestern ist der am polarkreis gestartet
durchs hochwasser in venedig ging es
dann nicht ganz so schnell voran
dafür aber nimmt er zu den kindern in
japan den direkten weg durch die luft
in deutschland sollte er sich regen
sachen anziehen trüb und grau ist unser
weihnachts wetter in den bergen immerhin
mit einer gewissen chance auf schnee
weiß gleich katja horneffer meine damen
und herren wir alle hier bei den zdf
heute nachrichten in redaktion
produktion und technik wir wünschen
ihnen ein frohes weihnachtsfest und wir
versprechen wir sind auch morgen für sie
da punkt 19 uhr freut sich petra gerster
auf sie auf dieser welt passiert so viel
was aufreibt umtreibt sorgen macht umso
wichtiger ist ein moment zum innehalten
machen sie sich einen besinnlichen
feierlichen abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren heute
nacht fällt viel regen und in den
mittelgebirgen und am alpenrand ist doch
schnee dabei bei lebhaftem westwind
die temperaturen sinken auf 8 bis 2 grad
morgen lassen die regen- und schneefälle
mehr und mehr nach und von der nordsee
kommt die sonne heraus
dazu steigen die temperaturen auf vier
bis zehn grad und der wind sogar noch zu
in süddeutschland sind sturmböen möglich
der zweite feiertag wird trocken am
freitag beginnt es von westen zu regnen
und in den mittelgebirgen und an den
alpen ist oberhalb von 700 metern auch
schnee dabei und jetzt wünsche ich ihnen
dass sie gelassen bleiben und geduldig
mit sich und den anderen fröhliche
weihnachten